congratulations on the movie
uh you were fantastic in it um
you've been in a lot of cinematic
universes and i'm curious
if when you heard patty was going to do
a star wars movie
if you were like you know i'm pretty
good in outer space
um and it's a franchise i've not been a
part of yet
[Music]
no i you know i i had spoken to her
about not my involvement about the story
she
talked to me about it and uh it sounds
really really great and um
uh but uh no i mean i i think uh i'm ex
i'm ecstatic for her excited for what
she's about to embark on if there's
anyone that can reimagine and
and breathe fresh new life into it it's
uh
it's uh it's her in an alt universe
captain kirk runs into wonder woman does
she give him the time of day
or she like just move along i don't
think
i think catherine kirk would definitely
uh
definitely uh throw his hat in the ring
and i think
probably be um uh
you know wouldn't wouldn't get the time
of day over there no
listen did you ever think that you
trying on clothing
um and having fun with it would be one
of the best parts of a huge budget
superhero movie
that day was so fun patty was like these
are the clothes you're gonna try on go
make a scene and i was like all right so
it was it was
certainly one of the more fun days i had
just because it was full
you know full improv and and just trying
to come up with bits that worked
um and certainly really fun you know
the whole idea about steve is that you
know you play with tropes
it's like in the first one i'm the i'm
the guy that
gets out of the bathtub without his
clothes on it's not the girl and this
one i get to play dress up like the
girls usually do in the phone so
there's a lot of gender play in it that
i think is really fun and hopefully
people
you know smile at and i'm really there
to fall in love with gal and
and provide some you know uh
provide some expositional wear when and
then you know just flirt with her so
it was it was a lot of fun uh but being
serious for a second i
i really just want to emphasize that's a
[ __ ] great scene
that i absolutely loved when what if you
did a lot of improv on that
what what was your reaction seeing what
eventually got cut together
because it's so well done yeah i don't i
really honestly i don't
we did so many uh
i'd uh i you know i'd forgotten that
parachute line i'd forgotten about
and uh so i don't know what ended up on
the floor
um uh i don't know what ended up on the
floor
um um
it was a fun day though i mean we just
did a lot of different outfits and it
was a lot of different comments of this
and that
and on that note thank you so much and
good luck with your speed dating
thank you steve appreciate it